If a person finds it difficult to keep the fast, then he should feed a poor person, so if a person is alive
and can't keep fast for any valid
reason, such as sickness and old age,
old man or woman, then one person should be fed
for every fast, he and she miss this
ruling as for a first  There is a concern if a
person does not
make up for the fast then you suppose he has to keep it so what ruling should he fast but there is a concern for
two
groups of scholars who are not required to keep it, but a person should be
fasted based on this hadi asha
ala pvir it is mentioned in Sahih
Bukhari number three in the book of fasting
hadi number 1952 hasha mala she set a person who has died who has to have fasted then his
guardian should fast on his before then based on this hadi
the first group of scholars say that they should
make up for the fast not a person who has to have fasted
but there is another group of scholars who are not required to keep it
but a person should be fasted based on this hadi
Based on this hadi an ash aasha
cha is there in Mahala Ine Hazam Volume 1
Page Number 422 of
Amra at
every mother mismatch of Ramadan so one can
fast no
mother no mother no one should fast no one has to ...  If a person who fasts mid-day is required to fast and fast at any
time, it is an obligation to do so
and fasting is mentioned
in the Book of Fasting number 25 in which case if a person who fasts
mid-day is required to fast and fasting is mentioned in the Book of Fasting number 25 in which case if a person who fasts mid-day is required to fast and fasting is mentioned in the
Book of Fasting number 25 in which case if he fasts mid-day then you should feed one person for every fast that he fasts mid-day and you need not make up for the fast, there is no atonement for fasting but a person who has to fast if he fasts mid-day is required to fast some wish which is fulfilled then in that case the atonement of fasting and
the fasting is complete by virtue of the law not being followed
in the Book of Fasting number 195 in which case one person should be fed for every fast that he fasts mid-day is mentioned in the Book of Fasting number
195 in which case it is said that a person came
to the Prophet and his
mother to make up for one month of fasting so he fasts mid-day but fasting is said in the Book of Fasting number 195 in which case
Good to make up fast but this general it is how it is
in the month of Ramadan which is
missed and how it is the fast of which and since we can not agree the sahi had can
contradict
so the best is the opinion second opinion that if a
person misses any fast in the month of
Ramadan then one person should be fed on his
bi half but if a person forgets and does not
fulfill the fast in this case the fast should be
made up by the er ok Shukra